dealing a major
blow to the biden administration and
reinstating the remain in mexico policy
this after texas sued over the program
suspension claiming it placed a burden
on local governments forced to provide
services to immigrants texas attorney
general ken paxton was behind the
lawsuit and he joins us now live okay
ken so first off this program keeps
migrants in mexico as they await these
hearings especially right now with the
influx and the surge at the border and
not only that but the the surgeon
coveted cases how important is it for
them to remain in mexico while they
await these hearings
so incredibly important this is one of
president trump's i think greatest
successes because we he had the same
problem he instituted this program
because all of these immigrants were
being told by immigration lawyers hey
come to come to the united states you'll
cross the border tell a border agent
that you're claiming asylum
and then you get to disappear into the
country for years you don't ever have to
come back and so this idea that you have
to stay in mexico and wait for your
asylum hearing is a really good idea
especially when only about 14
of these people qualify so it was
greatly successful under the trump
administration we're hoping that
reinstituting it will really help along
the border and then i want to get to
this this is dhs's response to the
supreme court's ruling it says dhs has
appealed the district court's order and
will continue to vigorously challenge it
as the appeal process continues however
dhs will comply with the order in good
faith how long could this appeal process
take
you know it could take a long time but
because we would still have to go
through like like a little trial uh on
the merits of the case however we won a
preliminary injunction at the district
court level in federal court in texas we
then took it to the fifth circuit we won
again we took the us they took it to the
u.s supreme we won again
so when you do that the court is saying
you're like likely to win on the merits
and when they're granting an injunction
so i feel very confident that they can
appeal it and we can go through the
trial process but pretty sure we're
going to win and we already have the
injunction in place so we're fairly
confident we're going forward in the
right direction obviously it's important
for you know the safety of america for
people to to come into this this country
uh legally but
texas in particular right now how
important is it for just the state of
texas
oh it's it's incredible i just met with
a bunch of ranchers a couple days ago
and they are so frustrated they're so
fearful because they're they're not only
their property being destroyed but they
fear for their lives i met with the
leaders along the borders they're
fearful they don't know how to deal with
the influx they're worried about covet
killing their people they're worried
about the importation of fentanyl which
is dramatically up because of the border
crisis and human trafficking sex
trafficking all kinds of different
crimes so we have a lot of problems
related to this and a lot of obviously
massively increased law enforcement
costs along with health care costs so
yeah it has a dramatic effect impact on
our state and as they import these
people all over the country with covid
you know this is going to affect the
health and safety of citizens across the
country as these people are moved around
secretly by the administration
and and with this administration with
with biden's words um
do you think that the president
respects the rule of law especially when
it comes to states rights or is he
basically just saying i can do whatever
i want it doesn't matter you know about
statute or any of the rights of the
states
no there's no doubt he looks at the
federal laws is sort of his choice if he
wants to follow what has been passed by
congress his job is actually not to
change the laws it's to follow them
whether he likes them or not i have to
do the same thing in the executive
branch he doesn't do that he says look i
don't have to follow the laws i was
elected president this constitutional
thing doesn't work for me so he
literally tells people not to enforce
the law and that's what's happening
along the border that's we have such a
disaster and you can compare what donald
trump did a year ago to where we are now
the numbers are dramatically different
the results are horrible and it's
because we have a president who
literally is out of control
and then before we do let you go um just
to put it in context july 2020 there's
40
929 border encounters and then july of
2021 there was 212
672 just to put it in perspective and
then this number right here um over a
million um as far as border encounters
and fiscal year 2021. okay ken paxton
thanks for joining us we got to leave it
here but we appreciate your take on this
and good luck in texas
thank you